it's PS Plus mid-month update time once
again I'll show you gameplay from all
the PS plus extra and premium catalog
games added in June 2023 and I'll also
let you know what's leaving this month
please leave a like if this is helpful
and please recommend a game in the
comments to make sure a great game
doesn't go unplayed hello there I'm Adam
here's everything coming to PS plus
extra on Tuesday June 20th well I wasn't
expecting this Far Cry 6 is coming to PS
plus extra the first person open world
shooter takes us to Yara a place based
on Cuba in real life and in good old Far
Cry tradition we are tasked with freeing
the country from the grips of a dictator
this time it's Anton Castillo played by
everyone's favorite bad guy from
Breaking Bad we joined the Guerrilla
Fighters and use anything we can get our
hands on to push the resistance forwards
the Fangs for higher system returns from
Far Cry 5 with a crocodile a [__] crawl
or even a sausage dog in a wheelchair as
a companion this story has callbacks to
other games in the series and ultimately
it's a great game that takes over 20
hours to finish on near a 60 for the
Platinum Hunters watching if that RPG
isn't for you then maybe Deus Ex mankind
divided is more your speed we play as
Adam Jensen a human with so many
augments it's tough to know if he's man
or machine and throughout the game we
add to that biotechnology to build a
character with skills that we prefer
while hunting down generic bad guys we
approach each mission in many ways like
maybe going in unnoticed could you get
to the roof without being seen or if you
prefer guns blazing through the front
door mankind divided lets us constantly
evolve our character to be the perfect
agent the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
are here Shredder's revenge is a classic
beat em up that were popular in arcades
in the 1980s and 90s playing as one of
the Fab Four or their allies in Co-op
Play We side scroll our way through the
Foot Clan and take on a boss at the end
of each stage from Bebop and Rocksteady
through to and the Technodrome it's a
short game and perfect for gamers young
and old each character has unique
abilities and prefer different ranges in
a brawl you'll have this done in a few
hours but completionists will take about
15 hours in total for the platformer
fans take a look at Rogue Legacy 2. we
control a knight who explores a
procedurally generated dungeon in
pursuit of treasure and challenge Rogue
Legacy as its name suggests is a
roguelike as should we fall in battle
the character is gone forever and we
return to the start of the game luckily
we have a child to take over and that
becomes a mechanic our ancestors
continue our life's objective and any
permanent upgrades are handed down from
father to son from mother to daughter
critics absolutely loved Rogue Legacy 2
averaging a huge 9 out of 10. hold up
the greatest game ever is here in June
my friend Peppa Pig with Cutting Edge
Graphics engaging storyline complex
multi-layered lore and intense action
scenes none of those things are in this
pepper game yet I don't know about you
but I can't wait to play it inscription
is another roguelike yet this one is all
about building a deck of cards but this
is only the beginning of what
inscription becomes and believe me the
twists and crazy changes won't be
spoiled by me right now if you enjoyed
slay the Spire this will take your
expectations to a brand new level just
don't spoil it for yourself go for it
play it average review score 8 out of
10. solstice is an action hack and
slasher exploring a dark World brimming
with hidden mysteries mastering a
diverse combat system which feels a lot
like Devil May Cry and inhabit the Dual
forces of Two Sisters in a dark fantasy
story with fast-paced vicious enemies
and spectacular boss fights coming in
June is Tacoma an exploration game set
in 2088 we use a version of augmented
reality to view the history of the
surroundings here kinda like Batman's
detective vision and by piecing together
what happened we get the answers we need
if that kind of exploration isn't your
thing then check out why out at heart as
we follow two runaway children as they
unravel the mysteries of this lost realm
over on the PS4 is Killing Floor 2 a
first person shooter released back in
2016 and not much can really be said
here it's a shooter and it does lots of
shooting vampire the Masquerade coteries
of New York takes the old tabletop RPG
and makes it into a visual novel I'm
sure someone likes visual novels on
Playstation is it you racing game fans
can enjoy MX vs ATV Legends to become
the champion of gritty off-road racing
or red out 2 is a fast-paced Sci-Fi
racer attuned like the old arcade
cabinets of the 1980s then there's
lonely mountains downhill a third person
biking game that throws us down a
mountain in the hopes of staying on your
seat and setting a new record when you
reach the bottom and the only other
sports based game in June is dodgeball
Academia we are a rookie dodgeball
player and while playing through this
RPG we slowly climb the ranks and
dominate both on and off the court is
there any simulator fans in the house
did you enjoy the Bus Simulator last
month well this month you've got 100
days winemaking simulator from choosing
the vines to cultivating the land then
drinking far too much at the end who
knew you wanted to run your own Winery
until you heard this sentence puzzle
fans your game this month is the Talos
principal deluxe edition a narrative is
thread through this entire world and
only your abilities to complete brain
teasing tasks can get you to the
conclusion the critics loved it it's a
smidge under 9 out of 10. Kato is
another puzzle Adventure outing as we
play as a young girl separated from her
grandmother after a storm we've gotta
reunite with Granny at any costs we have
a stealth focused game this month Thief
we play as Garrett a master Thief who
must survey his next mission get in get
the objective done and then get out
again preferably unseen tactics and
planning play a huge but in getting the
best out of thief a surprisingly
underrated game of 2022 is here elix 2
an open world RPG which combines a
primal world and also a futuristic world
and we must survive within it another
take on an open world Adventure is
forager we simply explore the world
finding resources these can be for
fishing hunting mining manufacturing hey
there's even some for magic too it
doesn't look great I know but reviewers
definitely enjoyed it averaging 78 out
of 100. for the kids check out DC League
of Super Pets and PAW Patrol Mighty Pups
Save Adventure Bay but if they are too
young for you my suggestion is a hat in
time a platformer open world filled with
puzzles it feels uncannonly like a
spiral game so it's definitely inspired
by it alas as every month with new games
joining PS plus extra some old ones are
on their way out the following 17 titles
are leaving less than six days after
this video goes live so play any quickly
before you are locked out the first and
third person destruction shooter red
factions one and two are both leaving on
June 19th as is the brilliant yet super
tough John Wick hex agents of mayhem's
time is up as two is fire pro wrestling
world and it's also your last chance to
play nine monkeys of Shaolin Ash of
God's Redemption Black Mirror defense
Grid 2 Gods will fall Lone Wolf kiwi no
straight roads party hard Redeemer
enhanced Edition and two versions of
Witchwood oh and also descenders
although that was a game on PS plus
essential too so if you claimed it on
that it should still stick around after
the update and finally over to the
Classics for June 2023 premium PS Plus
members will be receiving Killzone
Liberation from the PSP a game which got
me through many train Journeys and we
also have the iconic worms on PS1 and
also hooks Adventure 2. Paul did you
make it to the end of this video well
done if you did what are you playing
this month I'm Adam I'm knackered I'll
see you next time
thank you
[Music]